The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GUEST SPEAKER: Hi, everybody.
Today we're going to talk
about semantic localization.
So first I'm going to talk about
what is semantic localization
and what is the
motivation for it.
Then we'll go
through an algorithm
that will allow us to localize.
And then we'll go into
how to actually add
semantic information
into this algorithm.
So our focus what we're
coming up with this
was the orienteering
Grand Challenge.
So in orienteering,
basically you have a map
and you have a compass,
and you have to go around
to various checkpoints.
So as you can imagine,
this is sort of difficult,
because you don't know where
you are on this map except what
you can tell from your compass.
And so we weren't sure
how to do this either,
so we asked some
orienteering experts.
So basically the key ideas
are, if you are disoriented,
that's fine.
You just need to find a
reference point so that you
can figure out where you are.
You can think about
where you last
knew where you were, and
estimate what your movement has
been since you were there.
And that can give you some
options as to where you are.
And you can look
around for features
that you can identify
uniquely on the map.
And this is an example
of an orienteering map.
If you just have what's over
here, it's not very useful.
You can't actually tell
what those things are.
You might guess
that green is grass,
but you don't actually
know what they are.
This map isn't useful
until you actually
have a legend to go
along with it so that you
can say you have roads,
or foot paths, or pits,
or different things on the map
that you can actually identify.
So this is the difference
between how robots typically
localize and how
humans localize.
So humans think about
places in terms of features,
in terms of what you can do
with them, things like that,
whereas robots might measure
distances with laser scanners
to form a perfect map
of the entire space,
whereas humans might
think about obstructions
such as rooms and their
relative location to each other.
So we can define
semantic information
as signs and
symbols that contain
meaningful concepts for humans.
Basically different
sorts of abstractions.
And why might we want
this semantic information?
Well, one very
important application
would be improving
human-robot interaction.
So say you want a robot
that can make coffee.
It has to understand commands
like, go to the kitchen.
Get a mug.
Turn on the coffee maker.
This is the language
that humans think in,
and it's very useful if a
robot can actually understand
this sort of language as well.
Know what a coffee maker is,
what it does, and where it is.
And additionally, you can get
some performance and memory
benefits.
You're not storing this
full map with the distance
to every single surface.
You're just storing
locations of key information.
And this means that your search
base is a lot smaller too.
So you can prune
everything that's
not related to kitchens
or coffee makers,
and get a performance that way.
Finally, the fact that
you can use simply
a camera instead of a
complicated laser scanner
means that this is a lot cheaper
and more accessible for robots
to have.
So we've talked about what
semantic information is.
So now let's define what
semantic localization is.
So basically, it's
localizing based
on semantic information rather
than metric information,
like distances.
So for our Grand
Challenge, we have a map
with labeled objects
and their coordinates.
This is our semantic
information.
And we want to basically look
around and say, what can we
see in our field of view?
And from that, we
want to figure out
where could we be on this map.
And it's important to note
that map building is actually
a very different and
hard problem with a lot
of other research on it.
In our case, we've
been given a map,
and we're simply talking about
the problem of localizing
based on that map.
And now I'm going
to let Matt tell you
about particle filters, which is
an algorithm for localization.
MATT: All right, so
my name is Matt Deyo.
Now we're going to talk
about particle filters.
So this is a tool
that we're going
to teach you to
use, specifically
for state estimation, using the
given math and measurements.
So what is localization?
We just went over it.
Specifically, it's the
question of, where am I?
For any system to
work, the robot
needs to know where
it is on a map.
This is not so
simple of an answer.
Metric localization.
As was said before,
it is quantitative.
So how many meters are you from
this wall or from your origin?
What's your
orientation in degrees?
And here's some
examples of that.
You can convert between
coordinate frames
really easily if
you have metric.
So the localization is, well,
in our case, mathematical.
The problem statement
is, you have a control u.
You're going to observe
something about your state.
It might be a camera image.
It might be laser scans.
And then essentially
on your map,
you're going to use probability
to figure out where you are.
So this equation specifically
is taking into account
the probability of being out of
position at your current time
based off your previous
position, the observation
that you're taking
right now, the command
variable you gave it, and
then your map, like I said.
So that's built on the
observation noise, actuation,
and then the belief.
We're specifically
looking at the belief
here for the particle filter.
So in our case, we're
approximating it
by several points, also
known as particles.
So we're going to look
at an example here.
I have to actually
press the Play button.
OK.
Here's a quick demo.
[INAUDIBLE]
So a quick YouTube demo of
a particle filter in action.
So I'm just going
to show it first.
So pause.
The red dot here is our
actual robot position.
And it's trying to
localize itself in a maze.
There's black walls
throughout here.
And it looks like a grid world,
but that initial distribution
we had was completely
random across all the walls.
So it's taking in observations
of probably laser range
finders.
So it essentially knows that
there are walls around it,
and it knows that there's
not a wall in front of it.
So that centers all
of these guesses
on the center of hallways.
Obvious it got rid of things
that were close to the walls.
There's a low probability that
it's right up against the wall
because of the
observations it's taking.
And we're going to
revisit this example
at the end of the presentation.
Particle filters.
So the method that
we're going to teach you
has four easy steps.
One is not repeated.
So the initial step is your
first sample of particles.
If you don't know anything
about your state at the start,
then you can sample
just a distribution
of your entire space.
And then the repeated steps are
updating weights, resampling,
and then propagating dynamics.
So we're going to show
you a toy example.
This is a really simple example
just to get the idea across.
We're focusing on
just one dimension.
We have an aircraft
at constant altitude.
So take that variable out.
The only thing we're
trying to localize to
is a distance x over a map.
The sensor is just
a range finder down
to the ground at this
constant altitude.
And then the math
is a known mapping
of x location to
ground altitudes.
And we're about to
see what that means.
The goal here is determining
where you are in the mountains.
So here we have our plane.
As you see, we
know the map below,
and we know that it has to
be flying at this altitude.
So with a range finder, you can
measure different depths down
to the mountain.
So here we have long
distances, a medium distance,
and a short distance if it's
directly on top of a mountain.
Constant altitude, unknown x.
That's what we're solving for.
And then we actually have
a noisy velocity forward.
So we know how fast the plane
wants to be traveling in this
direction, but obviously
with some noise,
it could be travelling a little
faster or a little slower.
So the first step, sampling.
Our initial belief
here is that we
don't know where it is with
respect to these mountains.
So we're going to
actually sample
with a uniform distribution.
Well, this is as uniform
as I could get it.
So over this range, those
were our initial particles.
Essentially guesses for
what the x location is.
We're going to
update these weights
based on the observation.
So we get our first observation
from our range finder,
and it's this length.
So it's a long length.
It's, I guess,
green in this case.
This is our measured value.
Here are all the
values that we expect
to see at these particles.
So this is pretty easy to
calculate, based on the map
that you have.
The position of each
particle maps directly
to a range finder measurement.
So we're going to compare them.
So the likelihood
of getting these.
So measuring the likelihood
of each of these occurring.
And we're actually
weighting the particles.
So based on what we measured,
these are most likely,
so they get a larger weight.
And we are most
likely not on top
of a mountain at this point.
So those get smaller weights.
So we're going to
resample, given that.
So we're going keep the
same number of samples
the entire time.
That's just how this
particle filter works.
Except we're going to resample
across our new distribution.
So these are the weights
that we just came up with.
And we're going to
resample over them.
So now it's more
likely that it's here,
or here, or way over there.
And then the final
step is propagating.
So this whole time that we've
been filtering and updating
our weights, the way forward.
So we need to take
that into account.
So we have a forward velocity.
Let's say this range
is 0 meters per second,
to 5 meters per second,
to 10 meters per second
that you can see on this plot.
So we're most likely moving
five meters per second.
So essentially,
this is your change
in time between
sensor measurements.
Obviously if you're only
getting sensor measurements
at 10 hertz, then
you can propagate
in between each of those.
So here we are.
Using our new sample particles,
propagating them forward.
For example, this one moving
there is a low likelihood.
That's a large distance.
And these moving at
a shorter distance
is more likely, given our model.
So we have those new ones.
The new weights are now based
in the probability of it
transitioning to that point.
How likely is it for the plane
to move that far, essentially.
And then we repeat.
So we're repeating
the steps again.
We're going to get a measurement
in from our range finder.
We're going to compare it to
the map, to our particles,
keep the ones that are most
likely and weight them more,
and then propagate them.
So as an example,
here's time step 2,
when we're measuring the
uphill of this mountain.
Time step 3, now we're
halfway up the mountain.
So positions that we've
kept are at similar heights,
so here and here.
And then we can slowly get
down to differentiating it.
So now that we're on top of a
mountain, the only pattern that
matches that is here,
and maybe over there.
And then eventually, we
get down to these two.
And then eventually, as
this mountain drops off,
it's a unique position, where it
goes farther than that one did.
So in the end, our
particle filter
thinks that we're right
around here or here.
And finally, there's
a pretty high chance
that we're over that valley.
So we'll looking at
this, again, now that you
know how to do the filter.
And this will make a
little more sense now.
So they started with the
uniform distribution.
They had no clue where
they were at the beginning.
And as the robot moves
forward, they are resampling.
And the measurements
are changing, obviously.
Because it's seeing
these two walls,
and eventually, it sees that
there's doorway to the left.
And you can keep
going forward as well.
So eventually, that
geometry doesn't line up
with any other spot on the map.
Here, we see it nose
into this hallway.
I think this top
hallway is the only one
on this map that's that long.
But it still don't know
which direction it's going.
It hasn't been able to
differentiate that yet,
but it's about to.
So the only remaining
particles are here and here.
It knows it's in the
middle of a hallway.
And it knows it's moved about
two blocks now without seeing
a wall directly in
front of it, which
that doesn't occur
anywhere else,
without having another turn-off.
So it's about to solve itself.
Because eventually, it
sees this wall over here.
And those observations
don't match up
with what it's actually seeing.
So there we go.
There's a [INAUDIBLE] particle
filter successfully working
for a little robot
with a rangefinder.
I went too far.
There we go.
DAVID STINGLEY:
I'm David Stingley.
And now, after we've
gotten an idea of why
we want to use
semantic localization,
and how to use particle filters
to get an idea of our guesses
for initial
positions, we're going
to talk about how we can use
these two to actually implement
semantic localization
onto a robot.
So hearkening back to
the implementation idea,
we have three important parts.
We have a belief representation.
We have the actuation model.
So once we have a location,
how are we going to move?
As we said before,
if you don't exactly
know how fast you're
moving, there's
a probability you move to a
bunch of different locations.
And then finally, we have
an observation model,
which is the
probability that you
see some certain observation,
given you're in this newly
simulated position.
If we continuously solve
for our most probable x,
then that's our location.
So that particle that
is the most probable
is the place that we
guess we're going to be.
So let's look at a
pseudocode for what
a semantic localization
would look like.
So as long as our
robot is moving,
we're going to
make observations.
And those observations are
going to be [INAUDIBLE] z1.
Then for those
observations, we're
going to start off
our particle filter
and guess a certain number
of probable locations.
We're going to use our
actuation to update it.
And then we're going to simulate
observations at that location,
and compare what
we expect to see
for that particle on our map
versus what we actually saw
that we made our observation.
This is going to be our update.
And this is what we're going
to focus on understanding,
since a lot of the rest of
this is covered by a particle
filter.
So what kind of
models can we pick,
because we need to define what
our observation looks like.
And you get a lot of choices.
In metric localization, you'd
use a labelled laser scan.
You'd have perfect information
about the environment.
And so you can see everything.
It might be nice to
use a scene of objects
at specific locations, but
that requires once again,
a lot of information.
Now you need to know
where the objects are.
You need to have an idea of
its exact specific locations
and orientations with
respect each other.
Maybe it might be nice just
use, like, a bag of objects.
I see four things in my
view pane versus three.
These are all choices, and
we're going to take a look just
really quickly at what
the facts of these are.
As we've stated
before, there's a lot
of choices in observation.
It can get complicated
really quickly.
So just to impress
that upon you,
imagine if you
used laser scanners
when you have three
objects here--
for instance, a house, a
couple of trees, and a mailbox.
You check each line
for an intersection.
And then you have to figure out
what counts as your detection,
since you're going to
have to differentiate
what's in your scene.
The problem with
that might be is
that, well, you saw an
entire wall, for instance.
Where do you want
the house to be?
So let's say we
assume that objects
were a point at some point.
You either completely see
it or you completely don't.
That way, you don't have
to half-see an object.
You just check to
see if whatever
you want your
center of mass to be
intersects with your
current view plane.
If it does, then you're good.
The issue with that
is that, for instance,
something center of view isn't
inside the scene anymore,
you just completely ignore it.
We have the exact
opposite problem.
So you might want to make
it a bit more complex
and have polygons,
parts of objects.
Do you see some
percentage of something?
How much of it is
in the view plane?
It adds in a lot of
chance for errors.
And that's, I guess, the
big point here to remember,
is that depending on how we
characterize our observations,
we have different ways
to get things wrong.
So let's say, for instance, for
an observation like distance
and bearing to some new scenic
object, what can be wrong?
Well, you have noise
inside of your sensors.
Your sensors might
have limitations.
You can't necessarily
see to infinity.
So an object might
be too far away
for you to identify correctly.
It might be rotated in a way
that you can't necessarily
interpret it correctly.
How about if you want to have
your observations in classes
of objects, so of
just everything
being an obstruction, now
you have different types
of obstructions?
Trees are different
from mailboxes,
of course, in which case you
have a classification error.
What if you see a
tree and you just
think it's a really, really big
mailbox, or you see a mailbox
and you think it's
a really small tree
with a funny, little, metal top?
These kind of
errors can then make
your scenes look incorrect.
If you decide to have
sets of objects, well,
what permutations matter?
If you don't have a way of
differentiating elements
in the set, then you don't
know if two trees and a mailbox
with the trees on the left
and the mailbox on the right
or vice versa aren't
the same thing?
So with that in
mind, we're going
to be talking about
how we're going
to solve this question
of given some position
and your synthetic
view, how likely
is it that it's your
actual observation?
And for that, we're just going
to change what this probability
statement looks like to make
it a little more concrete.
In this case, Z is the set of
observed objects that you have.
So we're going to say that
there are objects in the scene,
and we put them inside
of this value, Z.
So for instance, you see a
house and you see a mailbox.
That would be Z. Your set of
objects is just two things.
We're going to use the bag
of objects approximation.
Y of x is going to
be the set of objects
you expect to see given your
map for the position that you're
at.
So given a position X,
Y is a set of objects
that you would see.
So you might be in
a position where you
can see a house and a mailbox.
Then Y is is a
house and a mailbox.
And X is just going
to be your position.
That's the element that we're
getting from our particle
filter.
So in our example,
as you can tell
by how much I talk
about it, we're
going to use just two
things, trees and mailboxes,
because I like them.
So here's my map.
There's going to be a long
road, and off to the side,
we have trees and mailboxes.
And let's say that
your robot wants
to be a paper delivery boy.
So he needs to be able to figure
out where the mailboxes are
and how far down
the street he is.
Because if he were to
throw the paper wrong,
he'd throw a paper into a tree.
So in this world, our robot is
going to be here, represented
by an orange hexagon.
And it has this field of view.
So given this field of
view, what does Z look like,
our actual observation,
one tree and one mailbox?
Well, for this case, what
we're going to say is,
we're assuming that as long
as the thing intersects
with our field of view,
we're going to see it.
So simple finding that.
We're just going
to say that we see
both trees and this mailbox.
Once again, we talked
about how difficult
it is to do this observation.
So for a simplifying assumption,
let's say that we just
completely see the tree.
So that's great for our
actual robot position.
But when we start
spawning particles,
we need to figure
out what we're going
to say they synthetically do.
So say we spawn a particle
here, and we spawn one
when we're just
slightly off the road.
We deviated a little bit.
We're further forward
than the actual position.
We drove into somebody's
house, another guy's house
in the woods.
Then what is each of synthetic
observations for these given
points?
Determining this is going to
determine how we actually get
that probability calculation.
So what do we need
to consider here?
Well, the first thing we need
to consider is classification.
Like we said before, with this
set of objects approximation,
it's important that you
understand if you classify
things correctly or not.
Past that, like we
asked before, we said,
wait, why didn't I just
see a tree and a mailbox?
Well, we need to know
if we saw everything
inside of our field of view.
Maybe we did miss something.
Maybe instead that old
scene saw just one tree,
one mailbox, even though the
other tree intersected it.
And noise can happen in reverse,
so we could accidentally
see a tree when there
actually isn't one.
And finally, we could
see things overlap.
We kind of ignored this before,
but what if two trees were
right on top of each other?
It might make it
kind of difficult
for you to successfully
see that there are
two trees there instead of one.
So to start with, we're going
to strike this assumption.
It will become more evident
later why this is important.
But for now, we're
just going to assume
that every observation
corresponds
to only one object being seen.
Otherwise, you could
end up infinitely
expanding your scene.
Think about it.
You see a tree.
There might be a possibility
that that tree is two trees.
Well, you saw two trees, then.
So maybe there's a probability
that each of those two trees
is also two trees.
And you keep going
and keep going,
until the entire forest
is behind one tree.
It would be kind of bad for
doing probability calculation,
because you'd eventually have
to cut that off at some point,
so that your algorithm
actually finishes.
So for our purposes,
we're just going
to cut it off at the start and
say that everything's just one
object.
It's just error.
So now we need to talk about
if we classify it correctly.
If we can solve this
equation, what's
the probability that our
classification is right?
So for now, we're going to make
two simplifying assumptions.
They're going to remove the two
problems that we had before.
And don't worry, we'll
relax them later.
For our first
assumption, we're going
to assume that we see everything
inside of our field of view.
So that means we're not going
to have any misconceptions.
And we never see something
that doesn't exist.
So we have no false detections.
Everything that's in the
scene, we see successfully.
If it's not in the
scene, we don't see it.
So given that, and we
spawn a robot here,
and it has this field of view,
What does this robot see?
AUDIENCE: Three trees.
DAVID STINGLEY: Yes.
It happens to see three trees.
So remember our assumptions.
We're going to say here that our
actual observation for wherever
our robot is is one
mailbox, and two trees.
And we can see that the
synthetic robot that we made
saw three trees.
So what are some
other forms of Y
that we can make that
would also map to this?
What's the way that we can
take our Y and transform it
so that it maps this Z?
What kind of action would
we have to take on this?
If you were thinking that
we'd have to misclassify one
of these trees, you're correct.
And remember, this is
just a set of objects.
So this doesn't have to
be the first tree that
got misclassified.
There's three of them.
We could have any permutation of
these trees get misclassified.
So it becomes important.
And we're going to
introduce this concept
of this operator, phi.
And what phi is
going to do is it's
going to be a way to map the
permutations that we could have
of misclassifications for
Y to look like Z. That way,
we don't have to try and write
all the permutations down.
It's possible to do this
essentially with a matrix,
like a permutation
matrix, that just reorders
the elements that you have.
So what does this
probability look like now?
We're going to use the
lower case z, y and i
to represent each individual
element of those sets.
So for some element in
the actual observation, z,
what's the probability
that some element
in our synthetic
observation matches it?
Well, for that we
need to pick-- well,
there's some
probability of being
wrong or a misclassifying,
or classifying correctly.
So we're going to use c to
represent a classification
matrix.
So there's some probability
that we classify correctly,
usually a higher probability,
and then some small probability
that an object becomes
another type of object.
So how often we misclassify
is represented here.
But we could add another term.
Let's say that our
classification engine gave
the weighted values of things.
It's common for neural nets
and other types of systems
that observe images to
kind of give weights
to their classification.
So you might want to use
those weights to represent
our confidence.
And there's a problem
that that confidence
determines that our
classification might just
be wrong out the get-go.
In that case, we
want to know what's
the probably that the
score is likely to be
that type of object.
And then we could
have other things.
For instance, let's say
that our classification
was way better at identifying
mailboxes from the front.
And if we turn the
mailbox to the side,
it gives poor observations.
And it tells us if it
thinks that the mailbox is
on the side, so it
doesn't really know.
In that case, maybe
having the bearing
of the object inside
of our synthetic view
allows us to determine
another probability
for misclassification.
The important thing
to notice here
is that we can keep
adding more terms to this.
The more specific your
classification can get,
the more terms you
can introduce into it.
So add some confusion to it,
and make the probabilities
of misclassification smaller,
and smaller, and smaller.
So with that in
mind, we're going
to look at what the probability
for these entire sets
is going to look like.
And what is really
is going to be is
it's just going to be a product
over all these classifications
for some selection of phi.
So you're going to have to take
all the different permutations
that you could possibly
have, and for each of them,
you're going to multiply
all of these probabilities
by each other.
In the end, it's going to give
you that entire probability.
So it's all the
permutations that you have,
and then just the probability
of each of those objects being
classified as that
type-- that you just
map one set to the other set.
So now let's take a
look at another scene.
So we spawned a particle
above, fake robot here.
And it has this field of view.
What does this field
of view look like?
If you said it looked like
two mailboxes and two trees,
you're right.
And so we're going to
assume that we have
the same actual observation.
We still see a
mailbox and two trees.
And we're going to remove
our old assumption.
We're going to say that
it might be possible
that we don't see everything
in a synthetic robot's field.
In which case, how can we amp
this synthetic observation
to the actual observation?
Well, we just add
in a probability
that we miss
identifying an object.
If we just didn't see
one of these mailboxes,
it looks exactly like this.
So for that, we want to capture
what's the probability that we
see nothing?
So say we have a synthetic view
with some number of objects.
What's the probability
we just miss all of them?
So the probability that
we miss all of them,
we're going add an
assumption here,
which is that we're going
to say that there exists
some probability that we
see an object for a given
synthetic view here, and that we
don't see it with a probability
one minus that probability.
So essentially, there's
just two states--
either we see the object
or we don't see the object.
And we're going to say that
probability of identifying
objects is independent.
So if we see one
object, then that
does not change our chance
of seeing the next object.
Both of these assumptions
help simplify the math here.
In reality, these might
be strongly interlinked.
For instance, if your
robot's camera is broken,
the probability that
it doesn't see one
object directly correlates
with the other ones,
because it won't see
any of the objects
successfully if it has
no camera any more.
If your robot
drives into a wall,
and can't see anything
because it's staring straight
at the wall, the same
kind of idea holds.
But for the purposes
of making it
so that you don't have
a lot of covariances,
and a really, really big
conditional statement
of a lot of probabilities
of seeing things,
we make these assumptions for
our items to be independent.
Independence means we can
multiply our probability
successfully.
So if we just don't want
to see any of the objects,
we just take 1 minus
the probability
of seeing the object for all
the objects in the scene.
So what goes hand-in-hand
with not seeing anything?
Think about if you
had a robot far off
in the distance over here.
What can it see?
Just two trees.
So now, we're going to
remove the idea that we can't
see things that don't exist.
So to make two trees map
to two trees and a mailbox,
we just made up a
mailbox of some noise.
So what's the probability
that we see a full scene
when we can't see anything?
And if you're thinking it's
going to map to a very similar
formula, you're kind of right.
But we need to figure out a way
to capture our noise statement.
Specifically, we are
going to use noise
as a Poisson variable, which
means that there's always
some probability of seeing
an object out of nothing.
And it's going to be coordinated
and according to this factor Kz
we'll get to on the next slide.
You could choose a lot
of different things
to represent your
noise in this case.
A Poisson variable was just
chosen by the specific method
that we used and implemented
from another paper.
But with testing,
you could find that
different potential
distributions
map to your noise for your
particular sensor better.
So with a Poisson variable,
what we're going to have is
we're just going to
have the product of all
of our Poisson variables times
this Kz factor for the given
scene that we want to map to.
Essentially, it's
just the product
of all these independent
Poisson variables
for each of our different
objects that we want to create.
So with that in mind, what's
this Kz factor that we're
multiplying everything by?
What it's actually
going to be is
it's going to be a set
of uniform distributions.
These uniform
distributions are going
to be uniform over all the
classifications we could get
for an object we spawned
from the noise, and all
the possible scores, and
all these possible bearings
for this synthetic object.
And if you remember a few slides
ago or you rewind the video,
you'll notice that these map
directly to the categories
that we put into that
classification engine.
In fact, they should.
So if you added more
things or took them out,
you changed this
uniform distribution.
The idea is that when
you synthetically
create an object
out of noise, you
might get any of those
types of objects.
But if you needed to create a
tree synthetically from seeing
it in the noise,
you might get a tree
or you might get a mailbox.
Either one of them
might show up.
If you had a different
or more intelligent
distribution for how you
might misclassify things--
for instance, let's say your
noise, whenever it shows up,
always identifies trees.
Whenever you accidentally
see noise as an object,
it's always a tree.
Then you might only want to have
a probability of seeing trees
over here, and it would
change you distribution.
But for simplicity's
sake, we're going
to assume that it's
equally probable
that any type of object
shows up out of noise.
So now, we're going to put
it all together, since we
relaxed our assumptions.
So we have a lot
of different things
that can potentially map
to this actual scene.
We have scenes
that lack objects.
We have scenes that lack
objects and therefore,
need to add the object in.
And when they lack objects
and have to add the object in,
there's a chance they add
in a different object.
And then maybe, they just
misclassify something,
like our misclassification idea.
But wait-- I guess we can
make this more complicated.
What if one of them
just wasn't seen,
so we'd take one of these out?
And then we just see
two things from noise.
As you could see, these keep
getting more complicated.
But if you think about it, with
our previous probabilities,
is every single one
of these is going
to add a lot of
probability terms
to be multiplied by each other.
You can keep getting as
complicated as you want it to.
If we removed our
first assumption,
we'd be adding in
probabilities of two objects
becoming one object.
The idea is like
higher power terms when
you're doing approximations.
The goal is to make sure
that any particle you spawn
could potentially be what
you've actually seen.
But we want the ones that are
very low probability to really
be very low probability.
So we make sure that these
incredibly complicated
transformations are going to be
so insignificant that they'll
usually return to almost 0.
So if we wanted
to solve this, we
need to start by using a
little assumption, which
is the fact that we now
have to fold in the idea
that we could have
some missed detection
and some false detections.
So false detections
would increase the number
of objects we've seen
over the number of objects
that are actually presence.
And missed detections would
reduce the number of objects
that are actually present.
Notice that this
always has to be
same size as the number
of expected objects,
because you're trying to map
whatever your synthetic scene
is to the actual thing
that you observe.
When you do this, it really
turns into a large number
of multiplications.
So this should look familiar.
This is our term for
successfully classifying
all of our objects,
and we're going
to multiply it by
the probability
that we actually identify it,
since we could now miss things.
Then, we have to multiply
that by the probability
that for whatever
objects we didn't see,
that we actually missed them.
And then finally, we
have to add in the noise,
because the noise is
going to make the objects
that we're missing
show up, so that we
have a classification of
the same size as the thing
that we want to see.
Now, one thing you should note
is that we added in phi way
down here at Kz.
That's because we have to map
these false detections that
added to the number of
objects that we could see,
as well as the
actual detections.
Essentially, we have to
take all the objects that
are seen here, real
or not, and map them
to all the objects
we expect to see,
because they're going
to be one to one.
So let's take a look at a
little video that shows what
semantic localization can do.
So in this video, for
a little heads up,
we have essentially
a scene where
they have mapped out two things
inside of a suburban area.
They've mapped out
cars and windows
on the path of the robot as
it drives around an area.
And they're attempting to
use just the information
of the cars and windows
visible on the scene in order
to localize where they
believe the robot to be
during its journey.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- This is a video
extension to the paper--
DAVID STINGLEY: So
going to mute that.
It's on.
So this is a few steps
into the process.
And then it resets.
It's spawn a number of points
for potential locations.
And then it very quickly
localizes and finds
its spectacular rotation.
These are all the
identifications
that are happening
inside of the scene.
You can see the boundary
boxes for cars and windows
showing up, the cars in red,
and the windows in green.
It expands out its
distribution of particles.
And then shortly
thereafter, it gets
a couple of approximations.
And then it settles
in on a location.
It happens to use a kind of like
a centralized weight for where
it is for the set of particles,
and then it draws the car
as being in that location.
If you let it keep
running, it occasionally
expands back out to
make sure it doesn't
fall into a local minima, and
then compresses once again
to where its
strongest belief is.
Notice that it has
a couple of seconds
of having a very, very spread
distribution, and very quickly
converges into a singular point.
That's because a lot
of these locations
become very, very
low probability
after you've seen a couple
of scenes into the future.
And we're going to pause this.
[END PLAYBACK]
I welcome you to go see
the video, to see the video
yourself if you want to.
You can check the title.
It's pretty easy
to find on YouTube,
because it's pretty
much the only one.
So hopefully, it works now.
Step back over here
to the other side.
So why would
semantic localization
be useful in this manner?
In the example that was
shown, it was kind of
done on post-processed data.
They took a scene.
They drove around it already.
Then they did the identification
on the video feed,
and used that to
do a localization.
We talked about before.
But people kind of use sparse
information to do a lot
of their-- or if you
can't walk into a room--
people don't walk into a room
and produce an exact laser
scanned map of the
entire area themselves.
But they can store
important information,
like seeing objects
and tables that they
find with their shins, and
use those to move around.
Robots store that perfect map,
if they can manage to make it.
But they don't really have
a good understanding of what
that map might mean to a human.
So that means that we're
actually kind of like better
at doing tasks with
the environment.
If we wanted to go
directly to a location,
we don't have to look
around and figure out
on a wall what our
distance from the wall
is before we can then
localize and move ourselves
back over to the table.
We just say, oh, I want
to go to the table.
And you look over there.
Oh, there's a table.
Table, got it.
So how can we make robots think
a little more like humans,
so it's easier for us to
give them instructions?
If we can make the
robot use a map that
has just scenic
objects like we use
a map that just
has scenic objects,
then order to move
between scenic objects
are as simple as turning,
finding the object, and saying,
oh, well, I know
where the object is.
So I know roughly
where I need to be.
And then we start moving
in process towards it.
In conclusion, semantic
localization has a lot of--
I'm going to leave the
references slide up
while I talk, so that if
you wanted to go and take
a chance to see any of these
papers, you definitely can.
Most of the work in this
slide comes directly
from these sources.
Semantic localization
offers us the opportunity
to take robots, use sparser
information to potentially
localize, find ourselves
inside of spaces.
It also gives us a chance to
have really tweakable factors
for how you might
understand where
you are in a space intuitively.
If you think certain
things are important,
you can add them in as
probabilistic factors.
If you don't, you remove
them just as well.
Thank you.
And this is essentially the
conclusion of our presentation.
I definitely recommend taking,
if you wanted to use something
like this, taking a look at
this particular paper here.
Notice how it says, "via
the matrix permanent?"
As I said before, a
lot of these operations
are a series of multiplications
and some permutations.
There's permutation matrices.
There's matrix multiplication.
And there's a lot of ways to
make matrix multiplication
faster.
This paper details how
you can take the math that
was shown before that's
pretty inefficient,
and turn it into
something that you can
do an estimate of very quickly.
[APPLAUSE]